okay
hi everybody
let's get started
so
um
it's been a while since we uh
came together in a lecture last week we
had the holiday we had the midterm
um
so uh with that um
where what have we been doing um we
finished the first half of the course um
you know about two weeks ago
where we talked uh we were talking about
computability theory we have shifted
into the second half talking about
complexity theory um so
get your mind uh back to that
uh we um discussed the various different
models um
[Music]
and and and ways of measuring uh
complexity on different models um
at least in terms of the amount of time
that's used and in the end we settled on
the one tape turing machine which is the
same model we had been working with in
the first half of the course and argued
that um
though there
the measures of complexity are going to
differ somewhat from model to model
they're not going to matter
different by more than a polynomial
amount and so
since the kinds of questions we're going
to be asking
uh are going to be um basically whether
problems are polynomial or not uh it's
not going to really matter uh which
model we pick among reasonable
deterministic models and so we're gonna
the one tape turing machine is a
reasonable choice
uh given that we defined time complexity
classes the time t of n classes
we defined the class p
which was invariant among all of those
different model deterministic models in
the sense that it didn't matter which
model we choose we're going to end up
with the same class p so that argues for
its naturalness
and we gave an example of this path
problem being in p and we kind of ended
that lecture uh before the midterm with
the discussion of this hamiltonian path
problem so we're going to come back to
that today
uh so today we're going to look at
non-deterministic complexity uh define
the
classes non-deterministic time or end
time
uh talk about the class np
the p versus np problem which one of the
you know very famous unsolved problems
in our field
and
uh look at dynamic programming one of
the most basic algorithm polynomial time
algorithms and polynomial time
reproducibility moving toward our
discussion of np completeness which we
will begin um
next lecture so with that uh let's move
into today's uh
content which is
well just quick review we
as i mentioned we defined the time
complexity class
this is a the time complexity class is a
collection of
languages
the languages that you can do
um
these are a collection of languages
all of the languages that you can solve
in
a certain amount of a certain time bound
within a certain amount of time so the
time
the time n squared for example is all of
the the pr all of the languages or all
of the problems that you can solve in n
squared times we're identifying problems
with languages here
and the class p
is the collection of all problems that
you can solve or languages that you can
solve in polynomial time so it's the
union over all time n to the k so n
squared and cubed and to the fifth power
and so on um union out of all that all
of those bounds um
the the associated language languages
that's the class p
and um we gave an example this path
problem we gave an algorithm for path
and then we introduced this hamiltonian
path problem
so
if you remember
instead of just asking
given a graph whether you can get from s
to t
now we want to know can i get from s of
t but visit every other node along the
way
so find a
a path that goes through everything else
and gets from s to t
um
and uh
i should say it's also it's a simple
path so you're only allowed to go
through every node just once
um
and now um
uh um
the question is for this problem is
that can we solve that problem in
polynomial time the
you know can we somehow modify the
algorithm for path to give us an
algorithm that solves hamiltonian path
in polynomial time of course we could
solve hamiltonian path with an
exponential algorithm by trying all
possible paths um
and that will give a correct
algorithm but
there are exponentially many different
paths and trying them all
will not give a polynomial time
algorithm so the interesting problem is
can we solve that without doing that
brute force searching through all
possible paths
um
and
that's a problem that no one knows the
answer to
um
despite lots of effort people have not
succeeded in finding an algorithm for
that but um on the other hand we don't
have any idea how to approve there is no
such algorithm
i mean it's conceivable that one could
prove such a thing but we just don't
know how to do it
and so um
that problem is an unsolved problem and
i just want this isn't really a note to
myself um
what's kind of amazing and this is what
we're going to be showing over the next
few lectures
that there are there would there would
be very surprising consequences
if you could find a way to solve
hamiltonian path in polynomial time
because what that would immediately
yield
is a polynomial time way of say
factoring large numbers or solving a
large number of other problems that we
don't don't know how to solve in
polynomial time so you know as we
mentioned you know factoring um isn't
problem that we only know at present
time itself with an exponential
algorithm
um and it doesn't seem to have anything
to do with the fact with the hamiltonian
path problem seemed very different
but yet
if you can solve hamiltonian path and
polynomial time then you can factor
numbers in polynomial time and so we'll
see how to make that connection um
that's what we're building toward with
the next uh few lectures
okay
um
so happy to take any comments on
comments and questions on that or we'll
just move on
um
if you have any questions on our little
review
well send questions along and we can
stop at the end of uh you know various
slides to to to try to answer them or
and of course write to the tas um who
can take your questions during during
while i'm lecturing
okay um
so to start this off we're going to have
to talk about
uh non-deterministic complexity as a
variation of deterministic complexity
so first of all when we have a
all of our all of the machines in this
part of the course and the languages
everything is going to be decidable and
all the machines are going to be
deciders so what do we mean when we have
a non-deterministic machine which a
decider is a decider
and that just simply means that
all of the branches
it's not just the machine holds on every
input but all of the branches hold on
every input
you know so the non-deterministic
machine is non-deterministic it has lots
of possible branches they all have to
halt
all of them on every input that's what
makes a non-deterministic machine a
decider and you can convert a
non-deterministic decider into a
deterministic decider
but the question is how much time would
that introduce how much extra time is
that going to cost and the only way that
people know at the present time
for
that conversion would be
to do an exponential increase um
basically to try all possible branches
and that's of course very slow
so um
let's first
let's understand what we mean by the
time used by a non-deterministic machine
and what we mean by the time used is
we're looking at the each individual
branch individually
separately
so a non-deterministic machine will say
runs in a certain amount of time
if all of the branches halt within that
amount of time
so you you know what we do
we we do not mean
that the total amount of usage the total
amount of effort by adding up all the
branches is at most t of n
it's just that each branch individually
uses at most the event that's just going
to be our definition and it's going to
turn out to be uh
the right way to look at this to get
something useful
um
so
um
if we have um
so now we're going to define the
analogous uh complexity class associated
to uh non-deterministic computation
which we'll call non-deterministic time
so non-deterministic time t of n
is the set of all languages that you can
do with a non-deterministic machine that
runs an order t of n time
um
just think back to the definition we had
for deterministic uh complexity the time
class or sometimes people call it d time
to emphasize the difference but let's
just say we're calling it in this course
time versus end time so time t of n is
all of the languages that you can do
with the one tape turing machine
that's deterministic um but this here is
a non-deterministic turing machine for
non-deterministic time um
so the picture that uh uh that
is good to have in your head here
um
would be
uh if you think of non-determinism in
terms of a computation tree thinking of
all the different branches of the
non-determinism
all of those branches have to halt
and they have to halt within the time
bound
so imagine here this is t of n time all
of the branches have to hold within t of
n steps for this
a non-deterministic turning machine to
be running in t of n time and to be
doing a language in the end time t of n
class
um
and by analogy with what we did before
the class np
is
the
um
uh collection of all languages that you
can do
non-deterministically in polynomial time
um
so it's the union over all the end time
classes
uh
where we the bound is polynomial
um
okay so a lot of this should look very
familiar but we've just added a bunch of
non-deterministics
and a bunch of n's
in in place but the definitions are very
similar
um
and one of the motivations we had for
looking at p the class p was that it did
not depend
um on the choice of model as long as the
model was deterministic and reasonable
and this is also the class np is also
going to not depend on the choice of
model as long as it's a reasonable
non-deterministic
model
so
it's again a very natural class to look
at from a mathematical standpoint
and it also captures something
uh interesting
kind of different from a practical
standpoint which we're going to talk
about over the next couple of live
slides which is that it captures the
problems where you can easily verify
when you're a member of the language
okay so we'll talk about that but
you know if you take for example the
hamiltonian path problem
when you find a member of the language
so that is a
graph that does have a hamiltonian path
from s to t
you can easily verify that's true by
simply exhibiting the path
not all problems can be solved can be
verified in that way
but the problems that are in np have
that special feature
that you when you have a member of the
language there's a way to verify that
you're a member so we're going to talk
about that um because that's really the
key
to understanding np
this notion of verification
okay so
let me go there was a good question here
let me just see if i want to answer that
um
um
yeah
mean
this is a little bit of a long longer
question that i i i want to fully
respond to but
you mean the the
well
let's turn to my next slide which maybe
sort of bring that out anyway um
actually it's a couple of slides from
now but i'll get to that point um
so let's look at hamiltonian the hand
path problem and what i'm what i'm going
to show is the hamiltonian path problem
is in np and i'm going to walk you
through this one kind of slowly
um so the hamiltonian path problem
remember we don't know if it's in p
but it is
in np
so it's in one of these you can solve
hamiltonian path in polynomial time if
you're a non-deterministic machine
um why is that well it's because of the
non-determinism
because of the parallelism of
non-determinism um
which allows you to kind of check all of
the paths
on different branches
so let me first describe how the
algorithm how i would just how i would
write down the algorithm and then we'll
kind of try to unpack that and
understand how that actually looks in
terms of
the turing machine
or the turing machine's computation
so first of all
so taking the hamiltonian path problem
you know you're given an input now which
is a graph
and the node's s and t where i'm trying
to figure out is the hamiltonian path
again which visits all the nodes
which takes you from s to t
and
we're trying to make now a
non-deterministic machine which is going
to
accept
all such inputs which have a path
so the way this non-deterministic
machine is going to work
is it's basically going to use its
non-determinism
to try all possible paths
on the different branches
and the way i'll specify that
is to say non-deterministically we're
going to write down
a candidate path
which is just going to be a sequence of
nodes sequence of m nodes where we'll
say that's the total number of nodes of
the graph remember a hamiltonian path
because it visits every node
is going to be a path with exactly m
nodes in it
so i'm going to write down a sequence of
nodes as a candidate path
and i'm not deterministically going to
choose every possible sequence
in this way
um
if you like to think of the guessing
metaphor for non-determine
non-determinism you can think of the
non-deterministic machine as guessing
the right path
which is going to be the hamiltonian
path from s to t but i think from for
this discussion it might be more helpful
to think about all of the different
branches of the non-determinism
um
because that's perhaps more useful when
we're thinking about it in terms of the
time you know i think you'll get used to
thinking about it you should be used to
thinking about it many in many of the
different ways but maybe the computation
tree of all branches might be the more
helpful one here
so now as after we write down a sequence
a candidate path sequence of nodes
now i have to check
that this really is a path
and the way i'm going to do that is to
say well now if i have just a sequence
of nodes written down what does it mean
for it to be a hamiltonian path from s
to t
well it better start with s
and end with t
first of all
and
we have to make sure
that every step of the way is actually
an edge
so each pair v i to v i plus 1
has to be an edge in the graph
otherwise that sequence of nodes is not
going to be a legitimate hamiltonian
path from s of t
and you could it has to be a simple pass
you can't be repeating notes
these four conditions together will
guarantee
that we have a hamiltonian path and once
we have written down a candidate
sequence we can just check that that
sequence actually works
um there's no at this
second stage of the algorithm
non-determinism is necessary this is
going to be a deterministic phase
but the
stage one of the algorithm is going to
be a non-deterministic phase where it's
writing down all possible paths
now i'm going to try to unpack that for
you so you can actually visualize how
the machine is doing this
um
and then of course you know so you're
gonna on each branch of the
non-determinism you're going to
check to see whether the conditions have
been satisfied and on that branch
if the conditions were not satisfied
that branch is going to reject of course
one of the other branches might yet
accept so
um
that's how non-determinism works
okay so i'd like to visualize this
um
uh
um
i'd like to visualize this
as a
uh
the tree
of
uh of the different branches of the
computation
of m on its input so here is the here is
our non-deterministic turing machine um
uh which this one um
and
you provided with the input uh
you know g s and t
and how does the machine actually
working
so when i say non-deterministically
write down a sequence of m nodes
you know
you know
this is getting into a little bit more
detail detail than i would normally
think about it uh because we try to tend
to think about things at a higher level
but just for just to get us started i
think it's good to think about this
with a bit more detail
so let's think of the nodes the m nodes
as being numbered having labels
numbered one through m
and i'm going to think about them being
labeled by their binary sequences
you know we're going to write down those
nodes that's how the you know the
machine is going to have to operate on
those numbers for the nodes we'll think
about them as being written in binary
and now as the machine is going to be
writing down let's say the node v1
so it's not deterministically picking
the first node of the sequence what does
that actually mean in terms of the um
the
step-by-step processing of the turing
machine m
well it's going to be
um
guessing via a sequence of
non-deterministic moves
the bits
that represent
the number of the node v for v1
you know for example v1 might be the
node number five
in the graph
um
of course you know non-deterministically
the machine is on different branches
picking all different possible can
choices for v1
those are going to be the different
branches here
but you know
one of the branches might be
and what i'm what i'm really
representing here these are
uh i probably could have written this
down on the slide here in in in tiny
font but these are like the zero one
choices
that's why it's sort of a binary tree
here for the
writing down the bits
of the uh of a v1 so here maybe this
could be one zero one
representing
uh the number five
which might be the very first node
that i'm writing down in my sequence
some other branch is going to write down
node number six some other branch is
going to write down node number two
because non-deterministically we're
making all possible choices for v1
that's what i'm trying to show in this
little
part of the computation
of m on this input
so then
after it's uh finished writing down the
description of the node uh
for v1 um its choice for v1 it goes down
to make choose what v2 is again
non-deterministically so there's going
to be more branches
you know
um for each
possible choice of v2
and so on node after node um
then it's going to finally get to the
last node vm is going to write down lots
of choices for vm
and at this point here we have completed
uh
the first stage of the algorithm now
there's some huge tree
of all of the possible choices for the
v's that have shown up at this point
okay
and
uh now we're going to move into the
second phase
so following this there's going to be
um
here
uh a bunch of uh deterministic
steps of the machine so no more no no
more branching no more branching is
needed uh because here
we've written down at this at this point
we've we've reached a point in each of
these um
at each
each of those locations where we've
chosen one of the candidates
one of the possible branches or one of
the possible paths through the machine
um one of the possible paths look
through the graph i'm sorry so we um you
know here we're guessing
uh potential paths in the graph
and now we're going to check that we
actually have picked a path that's a
hamiltonian path from s to p
as to t
okay so each each one of these branches
is now going to end up accepting or
rejecting and the whole overall
computation is going to accept if at
least one of them ended up accepting
which means you actually found a
hamiltonian path
okay so i don't know if that's helpful
to you or not but um
that is uh so we can just you know if
there's any questions on this let's see
um
question on you know is there something
um
uh
uh
you know
trying to draw a connection here between
this and and computation histories um
i mean
there is
a pattern here that does come up often
where you you you want to check some
things you know starts right ends right
and that all of the intermediates are
right so there is i think there is a
um
there is some deeper connection here
probably too hard to explain but
um
that does have something to do with this
hamiltonian path problem
um why are we using binary
representation well we're going to talk
about
um you know we
the algorithm would have worked equally
well if we used um
base three or base five or base you know
20 um
as a way of writing down our
labels for the nodes um
but in a sense it doesn't matter um
um the alphabet has to be finite so
that's that's true i mean that's why
you it's not just in a single step of
the turing machine
that you would pick
the
the node uh the true the choice for v1
you really have to go through a sequence
of steps because
each of the
branches of the machine only has a fixed
number of choices so you can't in a
single step of the turing machine
pick all the different possibilities for
v1 it has to go through a sequence
um
okay
um
now let me do a second example the the
problem for of composites
so the the
the language of all composites are all
of the non-primes
written as binary numbers again so we'll
talk about the base and the
representation in a second but just
imagine you know he you know these are
all of the numbers that are not prime
uh and that language is easily seen to
be a member of np
uh here is again the algorithm for that
um
given x
um we want to accept x if it's not a
prime number so it has some non-trivial
factor
so first the way the non-deterministic
machine is going to work is it's going
to guess that factor so it's not
deterministically it's going to try
every possible factor
what we're wrong y is going to be a
number between 1 and x but not including
one we you know that we have to be an
interesting factor so not including 1 in
the number itself so something strictly
in between
and we're going to then after we've
non-deterministically chosen y then
we're going to test to see if y
is really a factor
we'll so we'll see if it y divides
evenly into x
with a remainder of zero
you know if that branch successfully
picked the right y it's going to accept
and some other branch might have picked
the wrong y will not and if
x is really a composite number some
branch will find the factor
um
now the base doesn't matter could have
used base 10
because you can convert from base to
another um so this is really in terms of
our representation of the of the number
but i do want to make one point here
that changing
we don't want to write the number in
unary
um you know just as
writing the number k
as a sequence of k ones um that's not
really a base um that's just an
exponential representation for the
number and that changes the game because
if you make the input exponentially
larger
um
then
uh
it's going to change whether the
algorithm
relative to that exponentially larger
input is polynomial or not um so an
algorithm that might have been
exponential
originally
when the numbers written binary might
become polynomial if the number's
written in unary um
and i do want to mention as a side note
that the composites
language
uh or primes for that matter doesn't you
know both are in p
um
but we won't cover that
so
uh
whereas the hamiltonian path problem is
not known whether it's in p
the primes and composites problem are uh
np um so that was known there was
actually a very big result in the field
uh solved um
uh by folks in at one of the uh indian
institutes of technology uh back about
uh
you know almost 20 years ago now
um
okay um
[Music]
so let's turn here to trying to get an
intuitive feeling for pnnp and we'll
talk we'll return now to this notion of
np corresponding to easy verifiability
so
np are the languages where you can
easily verify membership quickly and
i'll try to explain what that means in
contrast p are the languages where you
can test membership quickly uh by
quickly i mean i'm using
polynomial time
um
that's going to be basically you know
for us that's what quickly means in this
course
so
in the case of the hamiltonian path
problem
the way you verify the membership
is you give the path
in the case of the composites the way
you verify the membership is you give
the factor
um
in those two cases
and in general um
when we have a problem that's in np
we think of this
verification
as having a giving we give it a special
name called a certificate or sometimes a
short certificate to emphasize the
polynomiality of the certificate
it's like a way of proving that you're a
member of the language
um
in the case of composites the proof is
the factor
in the case of ham path the proof is the
is the path the hamiltonian path um
contrast that for example if you had a
prime number
um
you know
proving a number is composite is easy
because you just exhibit the factor
how would you prove that a number is
prime
um what's what's the short certificate
of
um
proving that some number is it has no
factor that's not so obvious
in fact there are ways of doing it which
i'm not going to get into in the case of
prime
testing of numbers prime but and and now
it's even so known to be in p so that's
even better
but
there's no obvious way of proving that a
number is prime with a short certificate
um
and
so this concept of having
being able to verify when you're a
member of the language that's key to
understanding np
that's the intuition you need to develop
and hopefully take away from today's
lecture or at least you know by
thinking about it and reading the book
and so on
um
so if you compare these two classes p
and np
uh p first of all is
going to be a subset of np both in terms
of the way we defined it because
deterministic machines are a special
case of non-deterministic machines
but also if you want to think about
testing membership if you can test
membership easily then you can certainly
verify it in terms of the certificate
you don't even need the certificate is
irrelevant at that point because
whatever the certificate is you can
still
test yourself
whether the input is in the is in the
language or not um
the big question as i mentioned is
whether these two classes are the same
so does
uh being able to verify membership
quickly say with one of these
certificates allow you to dispense with
the certificate not even need a
certificate and just test it for
yourself whether you're in the language
um
and do that you know in polynomial time
uh that
that's the question
for a problem like hamiltonian path
uh do you need to search for the answer
um if you're doing it deterministically
or can you somehow uh not me you know
avoid that and just come up with the
answer directly uh with it with a with a
polynomial time solution
nobody knows the answer to that uh
and goes back at this point quite a long
time it's almost 60 years now um
uh
that
that problem has been around 60 years
oh that would be 50 years no 50 years
almost 50 years
um
so um
the uh most people believe that p is
different from np in other words that
there are problems in p that are in np
would turn out in p
um
the candidate would be the hamiltonian
path problem uh
but it seems to be very hard to prove
that um
and part of the reason is i mean how do
you prove that a problem like
hamiltonian path does not have a
polynomial time algorithm
um
it's very tricky to do that because the
class of polynomial time algorithms is a
very rich class polynomial time
algorithms are very powerful
and to try to prove there's no clever
way of solving the hamiltonian path
problems just seems to be beyond our
present-day mathematics
i believe some days somebody's going to
solve it but all right so far
no one has succeeded um
so what i thought we would do is i think
i have a check in here uh yes
and then we'll stop for a break
so let's look at the
the complementary problem hand path
complement
um
so that's you're in the language now if
you don't have a path
um so is that complementary problem in
np
okay so
for that to be the case
we would need to have short certificates
of
when a graph does not have
um a hamiltonian path
so
i leave it to you so there are three
choices
um
okay
i'm going to stop here so make sure you
get your participation credit here
um
end the polling now
interesting still the majority is wrong
well i know wrong we don't know uh
you know um
uh i i think the only fair answer to
this question is is c
um because we don't know
uh
whether or not we can give short
certificates for a graph not to have a
hamiltonian path
if if p equaled np
then you can test in polynomial time
whether a graph has a hamiltonian path
and then the computation itself would be
a certificate whether it has a path or
whether it doesn't have a path because
it would be something that you can check
easily
um
so
since we don't know uh
for sure that p is different from np um
you know p could be equal to np then
it's possible that
um
we can we could give a short certificate
namely the
computation of the polynomial algorithm
so the only really um
reasonable answer to this question is
that we don't know
um
so uh just uh ponder that i think the
the the thing that um you
those of you who answered yes
however
um need to go back
and and i ain't put this here explicitly
because i know this is a
th
this is a confusion for
well i can see for quite a few of you um
um
when we have non-deterministic
computation and you have a
non-deterministic machine you can't sim
simply
invert the answer and get back a
non-deterministic machine
non-determinism does not work that way
uh if you remember
you know the non-deter the complement of
a push-down automaton
um is not a push-down automaton
if you have a non-deterministic machine
and you invert all of the responses on
each of the branches
um it's not going to be
recognizing or deciding the
complementary language
so um
because
well i i think that this is something
you you if you answered yes
you need to
go back and make sure you understand why
yes
um is is not a is not a reasonable
answer to this question uh because
that's not how non-determinism works so
you have a
um
a not complete understanding of
non-determinism and that's going to be
really important for us going forward so
i i really urge you to figure out and
understand why yes is not a is not a
good answer to this uh to this check-in
okay so i think we will um we can talk
about that more over the over the break
um
and so uh we'll we'll return here in
um
in five minutes
somebody's asking about in
you know infinite uh
equal infinite sequences be generated by
the machine um
i you know when we're talking about
um
you know especially in the complexity
section of the course
all of the computations are going to be
bounded in time so we're not going to be
thinking about sort of infinite runs of
the machine that's not going to be
relevant for us so um let's not think
about that how does the turing machine
perform division
um
how does a turning machine perform
division well uh
how do you perform division
uh
the
long division is a is an operation that
can run in
you know the the long division procedure
that you you learn in a grade school can
you can implement that on a turing
machine um
so yes a turing machine can definitely
perform
do long division or division in one
integer by another in in polynomial time
okay another question can we generally
say
try dividing y by x or do we have to
enumerate a string of length y and cross
off every no i think that's the same
question
you know
i mean how would you know if you have
numbers written in binary how would you
do the division you're not going to uh
use long division
um
you know anything such as the the the
thing that's proposed here uh
by by the the questioner is going to be
an exponential algorithm so don't do it
that way
um
uh
why does primes in p not um composites
in p not implied primes in p it does
imply if
if composites are in p then primes is in
p as well because you can just you know
when you have a deterministic machine
you can flip the answer when you have a
non-deterministic machine
you may not be able to flip the answer
so
the deterministic machine just having a
single branch
um you can make another deterministic
machine that runs in the same amount of
time that does the complementary
language
um because
um for deterministic machines um just
like for deciders
uh
in the in the computability section you
can just invert the answer
uh there is an analogy here between
p
and decidability and np and
recognizability it's not an
airtight analogy here but there is some
relationship there um
what are the input like somebody's
asking me the implications of p equal to
np lots of implications um
too long to enumerate now but for
example
uh you would be able to break basically
all
cryptosystems um that i'm aware of if p
equaled np so we would have a lot of
consequences
um
so he's asking so composites
primality and compositeness testing is
solvable in polynomial time but
factoring interestingly enough is not
known to be solvable in polynomial time
uh so that i mean
so um
we may talk about this a little bit
toward the end of the term if we have
time
but
the algorithms for testing whether a
number is prime or composite in
polynomial time do not operate by
looking for factors
they operate in an entirely different
way
basically by showing that a number is
prime or composite by looking at certain
properties of that number but without
testing whether it has uh testing
but without finding a factor
um
uh
okay
another question here about asking um
the
uh
when we talk about encodings do we have
to say how we encode numbers
values no we don't have to we usually
don't get have to get into
spelling out encodings
as long as they're reasonable encodings
so you don't have to
usually
we're going to be talking about things
at a higher enough level that the
specific encodings are not going to
matter
um
okay let's let's return to our
uh
the rest of our lecture
when we talk about
say this p versus np problem
and
how do you show
that
uh
you know a problem
might not be solvable in p like the
hamiltonian path problem
um
you know many people
you know
who are
not uh practitioners in the field um you
know are know about the p versus no know
about the p versus np problems i i've
over the years i've got many many
emails and and and physical letters from
from people um
about that uh since people you know
since uh since i've spent some time
thinking i'm known as having spent some
time thinking about it
and um people claim to solve the problem
uh solve p is np
p the p versus np problem by basically
saying you know
problems like hamiltonian path
um
uh
you know or these or other similar
problems
basically there's clearly no way to
solve them without searching uh through
a lot of possibilities and then they go
through a big long analysis showing that
there are exponentially many uh
possibilities um
the
um
the
uh
you know
and a lot of the proofs that claim to
solve p versus np they all look like
that you only you only have to look some
somewhere in that paper there's going to
be a statement
uh along the lines
to solve this problem clearly you have
to do it this way
um
and
that's the flaw in the reasoning because
just like for the factoring problem
just like for the
uh compositeness testing problem you
don't necessarily have to solve it use
by by searching for factors there might
be some other way to do it you might be
able to solve a hamiltonian path
problem without searching for
hamiltonian paths there might be some
other process that you can use which
would uh give you the answer
um so i the class of polynomial time
algorithms is very rich can do many many
things and i and i i wanted to present
to you um
one of the most important polynomial
time algorithms in a sense it's kind of
the
you can make a certain argument that
this is sort of the the
the the in a sense the most fundamental
polynomial time algorithm
some people might argue with me on that
but
um and that's a process called dynamic
programming
which i'm sure some of you have seen
already in your algorithms classes
and some of you may not have but um
since you have a homework problem on it
um i i want to spend a little time
describing it to you
and that's useful for solving this acfg
problem um
which you may remember from the first
half of the course
involving testing
uh if a grammar generates a string
okay so remember this acfg problem
you're given a grammar
context free grammar
and a string and i want to know is it in
the language of the grammar
okay so that's going to turn out to be
solvable in polynomial time
but only with a kind of a clever
algorithm
remember it's decidable
we decided it by converting by making
sure that you are converting the grammar
into chance chomsky normal form then all
the derivations have a certain length
you just try all the possible
derivations of that length and you set
except if any of those derivations
generate w
okay
uh you may remember that um from the
first half of the course um
that immediately gives
an np type algorithm
for this language
because basically
you
non-deterministically
instead of trying the most sequentially
all of these derivations you try them in
parallel non-deterministically so
non-deterministically you pick some
derivation
of that length
and you accept it if it generates the
input
this fits this is
classically fits our model
of
of uh
of np
you can think of it as guessing the
derivation and checking that works or in
parallel writing down all possible
derivations um
but this acfg problem is
a
classically
uh an np problem
uh probably an in in np um
uh and if you just imagine
that
uh so and and then what's going to be
this the certificate if you found an
input that's in the language um that's
generated by the grammar the certificate
is the derivation
so if you look at it that way you might
think well that's the best you can do
this is going to be an np pro problem in
np and there's not going to be a way of
avoiding searching for the derivation
but that's not true there is a way of
avoiding searching for the derivation
you can kind of build up the derivation
um using dynamic program and so that's
what i wanted to kind of just describe
for you um how that works also partly
because it's a homework problem and i
think dynamic programming isn't is a
very important algorithm
so um
before we
um
uh
describe what dynamic programming is
which is very simple by the way um let's
try to work up to it by making an
attempt to solve this problem just using
ordinary recursion
um
so how would we solve the acfg problem
so you're given a grammar
you're given an input
let's assume the grammar's in conjunct
in chomsky normal form
so
that's going to be useful so it's a
chomsky normal form grammar and we want
to see how to
test if you can generate w
um
and it's going to be recursive algorithm
recursive algorithm is going to
actually sound something slightly more
general
i'm going to give you the grammar i'm
going to give you the string and i'm
also going to allow you to start at some
other variable variable besides the
start variable so i'm going to give you
a
some variable r and i know i want to
know can i generate w starting at r
okay so that's my slightly more general
problem which is going to be useful in
the recursion
okay so the input now to this this
algorithm is
the grammar the input and the starting
variable and now how is the algorithm
going to work it's going to try to test
can i get to you know is there some
derivation pictured here as the parse
tree
for w starting at r
that's what the algorithm is trying to
answer
can i get
w from r
the way it's going to do that
is
it's going to try to divide w
into
the two strings
in all possible ways
which sounds like it might be
exponential but it isn't
there's only a polynomial number of ways
to divide the string into two
substrings um just order n just
depending where you make that cut
so there's you know some
uh so that's not too bad there's a
polynomial there's only n ways of making
that division and also i'm going to try
every possible rule that comes from r
um that generates two
uh
um
that generates two variables so these
are
what's allowed in chomsky normal form r
goes to st
okay so i'm gonna for each possible way
of cutting w into x and x y and for each
possible rule r goes to st i'm gonna see
recursively can i get uh from s to x and
from t to y
so i'm going to use my recursion now now
that i have smaller
uh
um strings
instead of w
um i can apply my recursion and try to
answer it that way
and this algorithm will work
so if they if i found a way to cut w
into xy and i found a rule r goes to st
such that s generates x and t generates
y then i'm good
i know i can generate uh
w from r
okay and if there's no way of cutting w
up um to satisfy that or uh
you know uh if i can't find any way to
do
to divide w into x y and the rule r goes
to x t which makes this work
if all possible ways fail then you can't
get from r to w
okay
um
and then you can decide the original
acfg problem now by starting from the
start variable instead of just some any
old r you plug in the start variable far
okay so if this algorithm works
and
it
can be used to solve ac of g
but the question is is a polynomial
and it's not
because
every time you're doing the recursion
you're essentially adding another factor
of n
because here as we pointed out this is a
factor of n but that's happening every
time you're doing a recursive level
and you can imagine you know i'm just
doing a very crude analysis here
depending upon how you divide divide w
up but roughly speaking it's going to
get divided in half each time so there's
going to be log n levels
and so that means you're going to be
multiplying n by itself log n times or
get give you an n to the log n algorithm
that's not polynomial because
polynomials enter the constant
for some fixed constant n to the log n
is not going to be polynomial so this is
not a polynomial algorithm
so instead you're going to have to do
something just a little bit more clever
it's going to be the same basic idea
but just relying on one little
observation
and the little observation is
that
when
this
non-polynomial implementation that i
just described is actually pretty pretty
dumb
because it's doing a lot of
recomputation of things that it's
already solved why is that
because
if you look at the number of possible
different sub-problems here once i fix
once i give you g and and i give you w
um
how many
different sub-problems uh
g s and t are there
um
well the number of sub the number of uh
of strings here
all of those strings are going to be
substrings of w there's only
roughly n squared substrings of w i'm
always going to be generating
in a sub problem here some substring of
w from some starting variable um in the
grammar
so because there aren't that many
different substrings and not that many
different starting variables the number
the total number of possible problems
that this algorithm is going to be
called on to solve is going to be in
total a polynomial number of different
sub problems there aren't very many of
them it's only something like border n
squared
so if the algorithm is running for
exponentially long
long time it's solving the same sub
problem over and over again
that's dumb
why don't you just remember when you
solve the sub problem so you don't solve
it again
doing that
enhanced recursion where you remember
the problems you've already solved it's
called dynamic programming i don't know
why it has such a
a confusing name like that
actually it's called by several
different things but anyway
that's known as dynamic programming it's
a recursion plus the memory um
and here is just repeating myself um
there are
not very many different substrings um
so every time you're going to be in your
recursion somewhere you're going to be
working with a substring so there's not
that many different sub problems that
you can possibly solve and just remember
when you solve the sub problem
and not solve it again so
let me just show you that algorithm
again here with them with a little
modification
so first of all
let me give you
this is the same algorithm from the
previous slide i'm just repeating here
without all the other stuff so we can
just look at it directly right dividing
it
into x and y for each possible rule
and just and then recurse
now
i'm going to
add a little step 0 beforehand
um which says
if i have g w and r
let me just check first with i've
already solved that one before
so i have to keep track of the ones i've
already solved
that's not too bad because there's only
n squared order n squared possible
different ones that i could be called on
to solve
so i'm just going to have a little table
where i'm going to remember those
and then every time i get a new one i
get i get one to solve i'll check is it
on that table and what's the answer
so i won't have to rerun those
so now the total i'm going to be
basically pruning that tree
um so that it has only a polynomial
number of leaves and so the total size
of that tree now is going to be
polynomial um
uh and so that's going to yield a
polynomial running time this by the way
i only learned this myself i'm sure you
guys all know this who have taken this
as in the algorithms of course has a
special name called
memoization not memorization sort of
this came from the same root i think but
memoization which is somehow remembering
the results of a computation so you
don't have to repeat it
um
so the total number of calls is going to
be most n squared to this algorithm uh
because you're never going to be uh
redoing a work that you've done already
so and you know and when you actually
have to go through it
the the running time um
uh
um
you know so
it's it's the the total amount of time
that you're going to need is going to be
polynomial altogether um
so
let's here i don't remember what my
check-in is on this
um oh yeah so i mean this is somehow
related and feel free to ask questions
too
while you're thinking about uh this um
this check-in but the check-in says here
we've solved the acdfg problem in
polynomial time
does that tell us that every
context-free language itself
is also solvable in polynomial time
so just mull that over
and please give me an answer to it
i hope you do better on this check and
then you did on the last one um
but anyway why don't you go ahead and
think about that
and i can take some questions in the
meantime
someone is asking here
um actually i'm getting several
questions on this
why isn't it order n cubed or something
greater than order n squared because of
the variables
the variables are not don't don't depend
on n
you know when you're given
um oh well
actually that's not true
no
you you're you are right
um
uh because the grammar is part of the
input
so that you might have as many as n
different variables in the given grammar
so you you are right there is
potentially
um you know the grammar might be half
the size of the input
and the input to the grammar w might be
half the size of the input so i didn't
think about that but you're correct
there are uh potentially
uh
different numbers of variables in
different grammars so you have to add an
extra factor which would be at most the
size of the input because that's as many
variables as you could possibly have so
it really should be i think um order n
cubed um
to take that into account as well
plus all of the work that needs to
happen in terms of dividing things up
you know on a one tape turing machine
there's going to be some extra work uh
just to carry out some of these
individual steps um because with a
single tape things are sometimes a
little awkward i think the total running
time is going to end up being something
like enter the fourth or into the fifth
on a one tape turing machine
but
but that's a good point
so somebody's saying how can we be
storing n squared strings in finite time
i'm not saying what why finite time we
have polynomial time every every state
stage of this algorithm is allowed to
run for polynomially many steps as long
as it's clearly polynomial we can just
write that down as a single stage um
part two should say
oh
there's a typo here so use d
thank you that's that is a typo um
uh
i'm afraid if i change it on my original
slide here things will break in some
horrible way
let's just see that i completely wrecked
my slide
no that's good
yeah thank you good point
um
uh
oops
okay how's how's our check-in doing
okay i think you're just about all done
um oh that's still spent a lot of time
on this
and polling um
as you may remember from the first half
of the course
so the answer is is a indeed um
remember that we showed acfg is in
is decidable and therefore each context
free language itself is decidable just
because you can then plug you can plug
in the specific grammar into the acfg
problem
the very same reasoning works here
um you can for if if you have a
context-free
language it has a grammar you can plug
that grammar into the acfg problem
and then that's polynomial time you'll
get you're going to get a polynomial
time algorithm for that uh for that
language um so good to review that um
it's it's the same thing from same
argument we used before
um
okay
also i i
i want to spend a lot of time on this
there are there's another way of looking
at dynamic programming we'll talk about
this again um maybe in a lecture
probably next lecture just because i
know you have a homework problem on it
and um if if you've seen dynamic
programming before is going to be easy
if you haven't seen it before it's going
to be i think probably a little
challenging
but
another way of looking at dynamic
programming is the so-called bottom-up
version of dynamic programming and what
that would mean is you solve all of the
sub-problems first before you solve all
the smaller sub-problems before you
solve the larger sub-problems um let me
just
you know i
i it's here on the slide i'm not sure i
want to talk it through but basically
um
you solve
this the sub problems here
where um
the strings are start with strings of
length one
and then from that you build up to sub
problems where the substrings are of
length two
and then three and so on and each of
those only relies on the smaller
previously solved sub problems so you
can
kind of in a systematic way
solve all the larger and larger
subproblems uh you know for larger and
larger substrings
and
that gives a kind of a different
perspective on dynamic programming and
kind of for different problems sometimes
it's better to think about either the
sort of top-down recursion-based
process or the sort of the bottom-up uh
process that i'm describing here um
they're really completely equivalent um
but uh
you know
the version that's described for this
particular algorithm which appears in
the textbook is actually the bottom-up
algorithm um so you shouldn't be
confused if you see something there
which looks somewhat different
and that's often you see you basically
solve all possible sub problems
filling up basically filling out a table
um
let me not say it anymore
say anything more about that here since
we're running a little short on time um
but um
there are really two perspectives on
dynamic programming
okay so moving on from there um
let's let's shift gears
uh leave context free languages and uh
dynamic programming behind
um and start moving toward understanding
um
p and np
and for that we will
um
introduce a new problem called the
satisfiability problem and that's one
we're going to spend a lot of time on
so
important to
if you tuned out a little bit during the
dynamic programming
discussion
time to get back on board
so the satisfiability problem is going
to be a computational problem um
uh that
we're going to be working on and it has
to do with boolean formula
so these are like expressions like
arithmetical formula like
x plus y
times z
but instead of using um
numerical
variables we're going to be using
boolean variables that take on boolean
values true false or sometimes
represented by one and zero
and the operators that we're going to be
using are going to be the and or and
negation operations
and or not
okay um
i'm going to say such a very such a
formula such a boolean formula we're
going to call it satisfiable we'll do an
example in a second
if that formula value evaluates to true
um if you assign
make some assignment the values to its
variables
so just like arithmetic their formula
will have some value if you plug in
values for the uh
boolean formula is going to have some
value if you plug in boolean values for
its variables and i want to know is
there some way to plug in values which
makes the whole thing evaluate the true
the the formula itself is going to
evaluate to some either true or false
and i want it to evaluate to true
um
so
uh here is our example that let's take
the formula fee
which is x or y
and
x complement
you know or not x or not y
so the notation x
with a bar over it x
x complement is just x bar
not x
is just
the way if you're familiar with the
other notation
uh for the the not operation
we just inverts ones and zeros um
we we would write it we're going to
write it with a bar instead of the
negation symbol so i i'm assuming that
you've all seen boolean algebra boolean
arithmetic before you know where you
know the and operation is only true
if both inputs are true so these are
going to be binary and operations in
binary or operations
um or is going to be true if either
input is true and not as true if it's
single input is false
so it just flips the answer
okay so here i want to know for this
formula for this boolean formula here is
it satisfiable
is there some way to assign values to
the variables
to make this formula evaluate to true
so for example let's just try things
let's make x and y both true
so x is true and y is true
so x or y well that's good that's true
but now we have to do an and so we need
both sides to be true
so now now we have x complement well we
said we said x is true so x complement
is false y complement is false false or
false is false so now we have a true and
false that's going to be false
we did not find a satisfying assignment
but maybe there's another one and in
fact there is if you make x true and y
false
then both of these parts
will be evaluate to true and then you'll
have true and true so we found a
satisfying assignment to this formula it
is in fact
uh satisfiable so if you say x is 1 and
y 0 yes this is satisfiable
now the problem of testing for a boolean
formula if it is satisfiable is going to
be the sat language
it's a set it's a collection of
satisfiable boolean formula
and testing whether you're in sat or not
is going to be a
an important computational problem
and
there was an amazing
theorem
which really got this whole subject
going
uh discovered independently
by uh
steve cook
in north america and lane 11 in the in
the former soviet union
almost exactly at the same time
which made a connection between this
one problem and all of the problems in
np
so by solving this one
satisfiability problem
in polynomial time
you you there
it give it it allows you to solve all of
the problems in np in polynomial time
so if you could solve this problem sat
in in in p then hamiltonian path is also
solvable in p it's kind of
you know
step back and think about that it's kind
of amazing um
[Music]
and the method that we're going to
introduce is called polynomial time
reducibility
and let's do a quick checking on this
this should be an easy one um
i want to just think about is sat the
sat problem that we just described here
is that in np
three seconds
you all there
okay
ending polling
um
yeah so the a
hopefully you're getting the intuition
for np uh that
these are the problems to be an np means
that when you're a member of the
language
there's a short proof or a short
certificate
of membership in this case the short
certificate that the formula is
satisfiable is the assignment which
makes it true also called the satisfying
assignment
so yes this is an np language
language that's in np
um
uh so there are a lot of things that we
don't know in this subject but
this isn't one of them we do know that
sat is an np
so let's talk about our method um
for showing this uh remarkable fact that
if you can solve pollen if you can solve
if you can solve sat in polynomial time
then all of np is solvable in polynomial
time and it uses this notion of
polynomial time reducibility which is
just like mapping reducibility that i
hope you've all grown to know and love
in the first half of the course
but now the reduction has to operate in
polynomial time
so it's the same picture that we had
before
mapping a to b
transforming a questions to b questions
but now the transformation has to
operate quickly
and we get that
if a is polynomial time reducible to b
and b is polynomial time
then a is also polynomial time
same pattern as before
if a is reducible to b and b is easy
then a is easy um
and here is
kind of the essence of the idea
or at least the outline in a sense the
idea of of this cook and levin theorem
that if satisfiability is in p then
everything in np can be done in p
which is because we will show
that all problems in np are polynomial
time reducible to set
that's the amazing fact
so therefore if you can
bring sat down into p
by using this reduction it brings
everything else along with it because
everything is reducible to the set so we
just have to show how to do that
and there is an analogy that we had in
the first half of the course in one of
our homework problems if you may
remember
we showed that atm
has the very special property
that all touring recognizable languages
are mapping reducible to it
i think that was problem
2
on
2a
either in this problem set 3 or problem
set 2.
i think problem said three
um
that every
every entering recognizable language is
polynomial time reducible to atm
and so
very similar picture and there's the
a lot of analogies here that you can
draw between between
uh the computability section and the
complexity section
anyway
with that i know we're just about out of
time so let's quick review um
of what we've done um here
and um i will stick around for questions
for a while
is there a
okay that's a good question is there
kind of a you know a um
sort of a regular reduction analogy
version to mapping reducibility you know
we had that we had the general reduction
uh for the computability section
and we had the mapping reduction for the
computability section here
we're only going to be focusing
now on the mapping
reduction so polynomial time reduction
is
by assumption going to be a mapping
reduction yes there is a
general
polynomial time reduction notion as well
if you
you know this is not required but if you
are curious about the general reduction
and how to precisely formulate that it
actually appears in
uh chapter six under turing reducibility
um that's the general notion of
reducibility spelled out in a formal way
and there's polynomial time touring
reducibility as well we're not going to
talk about it this in this course
um
other questions
does np correspond exactly
to verification in polynomial time if
well we have to
for me to answer that as a precise
question we have to have a precise
definition of verification but with the
right
definition the answer is yes
um
so you can define a verifier
as a polynomial time algorithm
um that gives a certificate given that
takes a certificate and an input to the
language and will um
you know
accept if they're if that certificate is
a valid certificate for that input um
this is actually discussed in chapter i
think nine
um
of the text
uh but um
uh you
um
no i'm forgetting already what's where
in the book but yeah you can think of it
you can think of np in terms of
verification as a definition
uh
is proving people np the same as proving
that a problem you know actually i can
even make the
if you want you can
post public
comments too as well should have done
that in other cases
if is proving p equal np the same as
proving that a polynomial time
non-deterministic turing machine n
has a polynomial time deterministic
yeah so it
doesn't mean that
suppose we prove that p equals np
which is
the minority view i would say uh quite
the small minority view that that
there are some people who believe that
that
that that is uh entirely possible and
might even be the case but that's a very
small small group um
but yeah if you proved p equal np that's
the same as saying that every
non-deterministic polynomial time
turing machine is going to have a
companion
deterministic polynomial time turing
machine which does the same language
that's exactly what it
bye
means
you